[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote webinar titled torwards
multi-stem neural network models of
brain functions this webinar is part of
the 11th annual event in the
Neuroscience virtual event series and
I'm Susie Valdez of labots and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots so let's get started before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our live chat feature during this
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the left of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of this
presentation now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on that help desk button
located at the top of your screen within
the navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract tab from the
window on the left of your screen and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speaker Dr
Robert Young an assistant professor in
the department of brain and cognitive
sciences and computational
neuroscientist at Massachusetts
Institute of Technology for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the presenter tab from the menu on the
left of your screen Dr Young welcome
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
sir thank you uh thank you for the
invitation U from Lab roots and um thank
you for the introduction so do I click
push to audience I guess okay so um okay
so I'm going to talk about uh towards oh
okay I I can I can see the group chat as
well seeing some some friends uh towards
multi-stem Network models for cognitive
uh neuroscience
um so so I'll start with some high level
opinion and then I'll talk about two
concrete uh stories that we have been
working on uh neither is published yet
so so welcome any feedback um for many
of you this is kind of a cliche but I'll
still mention it anyway so neuron
networks artificial neuron networks
right so the the kind of Powerhouse
behind AI um is not only useful for AI
but it it can also help us understand
brains and Minds uh so many people have
uh talked about it um so so together
with Shing one so we wrote this little
primer piece that kind of help uh Orient
people who are new to this topic so this
is kind of like a educational uh piece
um so so if you want to get into this
field you're welcome to check it out but
so neuron networks can be used as data
analysis tools so this is similar to how
it's being used
for uh in other fields as well but uh it
has a special relationship with the
brain as in it can be used directly uh
or or after some modification as
computational models of the brain um so
and they're useful because they can help
us model complex behaviors they can help
us model complex activity patterns and
they can help us understand uh the brain
from an optimized ation perspective or
or uh people call Deep learning
perspective where uh for example besides
looking at the specific mechanisms of
how some function is carried out in the
neuron Network you can try to understand
the constraints the arch
neuroarchitecture constraint the
optimization process and the objective
function that the network is trying to
achieve um so this is similar to how we
understand biologies through uh uh EV
ution
Theory okay so um today I will focus on
a general purpose recurrent neuron
networks and they're used uh for
cognitive Neuroscience so recurrent
neuron networks are a particular kind of
artificial neuron networks and people
have been studying them for many many
decades uh now uh for about 20 30 years
people have studied general purpose
recurrent neuron networks so these are
networks that can be uh trained to do
many many different task and I'll
explain to you in some more details so
first usually we start with some
cognitive task because this is uh to to
understand cognitive Neuroscience right
how how people and animals think and
make decisions Etc so you would start
with a cognitive task so we would keep
going back to this classical task
developed by Mono shoi andum um so in
this case
the monkey would look at uh some colored
random dots and these dots are moving
left and right and the colors are uh
green and red and the monkey depending
on this little context cue that is on
bottom of the screen they have to decide
either uh the whether the dots are more
red versus green or whether the dots are
moving to the left or to the right so
this is uh a so-called context dependent
decision making task right so you would
take a task like this or you can take
other task uh that people have trained
animals to do or humans to do and then
you take a recurrent neuron Network so
these networks are called recurrents
because um so the the neurons are are
usually connected to one another uh and
quite often there's no structure but you
can also add some structure in it so
they can be sparsely connected for
example but let's say for now that these
neurons are connected all to all so
everyone is connected to everyone and
and what you will do is then adjust the
connections in the network so between
the neurons so that this network can do
U this cognitive task right uh and
usually the way that you adjust it the
most common way is to take something
from machine learning let's say a
gradient uh gradient descent method but
you can also use other learning rules if
you want and we'll talk about that um so
with this three elements right the
learning problem um the network
architecture and some learning rule then
we can produce a network that can do the
task and then at the same time we can
compare uh this network to an animal
that has learned to do this task and
specifically from the recording brain
recording from that animal that can do
this task so so I'm I'm not going to
explain this but um so essentially you
can do some specific analysis of the
data and comparing compare that across
uh the uh the model and the brain so
this is a a pretty pretty uh classical
Paradigm I would say now it's used in
many many studies um but today I'll
mainly talk about the the problem with
that and how we need to move Beyond it
um so uh so together with Francis son
and judging one so back in 2016 and that
feel like a really a long time ago so we
also try to use this Paradigm for many
other task and uh in most cases we're
able to reproduce in our model what
people have found in the data right so
which shows that this Paradigm uh just
like many others have shown is this can
be quite useful but um but I'll first uh
share some opinion about why we have to
move Beyond
so there are many many challenges with
using artificial networks to model the
brain I talked about the advantage right
before but uh there are also many
problems some are shared across other
domains for example uh we talked about
the learning rule is often back
propagation a grent descent based that
is powered through this back propagation
algorithm and it's been known for 30
years that's that's uh it's not obvious
how the brain can do it although there's
a lot of cool work showing that maybe
the brain can do it in some form um but
this is this is a a problem that is
shared with other applications and then
there's a a problem of neuron networks
being hard to
interpret um so that's also a general
problem but there are also some specific
problems when you use these uh recurrent
networks in this Paradigm to model
cognitive task uh so one thing is that
uh so cognition is is really it's
flexible right it's not about just doing
one thing oh
sorry uh the odor is around here so
first is cognition involves many regions
so people have shown that um usually for
decision making there's widespread uh
computation across the brain both in
cortical and sub subcortical areas that
are involved uh for for any cognitive
task so when we use a single recurrent
Network here right that's clearly uh not
sufficient to to capture the diverse um
responses across these many many brain
reges another problem is cognition is
very flexible right but when you use a
single recurrent Network an RNN and you
train it on a one task it's not flexible
right that's all it can do is that task
so that's that's another problem um and
another Pro uh and another problem is
usually when animals or humans go into
the lab and trying to learn and perform
a task you're not starting from like a
random neuron Network in your brain
right your brain has existing circuitry
it you can already do many things and
you're building on top of that but when
you train a network from scratch then uh
you're essentially ignoring all the
evolution and developmental history
right and that that can lead to a lot of
problems as well so there there are
other problems but I think these three
are really fundamental challenges to
this classical Paradigm of using
recurrent neuron networks for for
cognitive neurosci so how do we move
beyond
that um if we describe this first
generation broadly as a single task
single
Network and using some back propagation
so um so in this little opinion piece uh
that Manu Milano maon and I published U
couple years ago we argued that okay we
need to really to move Beyond it and we
need to go to a future where our Network
are focused on really naturalistic
cognition that is flexible and can do
many many things uh we have to think
about multiple brain re regs and perhaps
multiple cell types uh and then we need
to think about biological learning rules
and and diverse plusy rules so and I
want to emphasize that we have to do
that not just because these are things
that exist in the brain right we're not
we're not advocating for just putting
things in your network because they
exist in the brain uh we're advocating
to to think about these things because
otherwise we might be studying current
networks artificial networks that are
operating in fundamentally different
ways from the
brain so uh and over the years uh so uh
I have um been fortunate to participate
in in uh some works that te that kind of
touch upon all of these uh different
problems uh I won't go into them today
but you're welcome to uh to check some
of these papers out um so but to to just
to summarize what I've said about this
opinion part is um is that we need to
move forward from you know this
classical Paradigm to build these multi-
region multi cell type uh multi plus C
rules Network that can perform more
natural
cognition um and this is I think uh in
some way echoed by uh folks in AI when
they're saying we need to build models
that are not just a single monolithic
network but the Network that has like
diverse uh diverse modules uh focus on
different
functions so so today uh so that's
that's the end of my opinion part now
I'll show you some actual signs okay and
um and I'll Focus today on on the
multi- system part so what do I mean by
multi- System right so so uh in this in
the middle of this Future Part I talked
about multi area so this means
multibrain regions but if you think
Beyond just brain regions you can think
about how the brain consists of
different neuros systems like visual
system uh cognitive system Moto system
and so on right so this is a course
separation and it's it's it's not so
clean but um but for now let's just say
there differ system systems and usually
people focus on individual systems at a
time right there can be multiple brain
regions in each system but really the
brain is integrative and involve
multiple
systems so so today we will focus on
Multi system Network so going even
Beyond multi area network and I want to
first show you that how multisystem
models can offer new insights into
classical questions right as a way to
show you why we should care about these
multistem
models so I'll focus on uh a a problem
that is really close to my heart so this
is uh when I did my PhD in Shing Wes Lab
at
NYU the lab is kind of famous for
studying working memory and decision
making um and and working memory is a
capability to to keep uh for example
some some items and some objects in a
short amount of time uh in your mind and
then maybe um manipulate that uh that
object uh and use it for future future
use so this is a really important
function yet it is severely limited so
people have known for really 70 years
that working memory has a very very
strong cap capacity limit right so I can
for example ask you to remember some
numbers and some people can remember
some numbers better than others but
usually people can only remember
something like uh four or two to eight
numbers right if I if I tell you some
random numbers so this is kind of odd
right because we have so many neurons in
our brain and this is something that a
computer can do trivially right and we
could we could do it easily as well if
we have some paper and pen so how come
our brain with all this neurons is so
bad at it right and we have
known this phenomena for 70 years it is
it is one of the first phenomena that we
know in cognitive science and yet we
still don't know why right we have a lot
of quantification of it um like the
exact capacity but we don't know why it
it's here
so uh so of course people have proposed
different ideas so the psychologists
have proposed that maybe that's because
we have limited slots or limited memory
resources right in our brain but it's
not satisfying these explanations are
not satisfying because it's like why do
we have limited slots right why do we
have limited resources where you're kind
of kicking the ball farther down the
line and we're still not answering
the the question why right um now then
some people proposed uh some neurom
mechanistic answers to why we have a
limit right so one influential idea is
that
uh memories are stored in these
so-called attractors and it's okay if
you don't know what that means um but
then these attractors would interfere
with one another right and another idea
is is that uh working memory is stored
in oscillatory patterns um and and you
can only fit so many uh items in your
memory in one oscillation cycle and so
and another idea which is kind of a
neural instantiation of the resource
idea in Psychology is that uh we have
limited number of spikes in our brain
right so at any given moment we have
only this many spikes so and and you
have to use spikes to encode information
right so if you have a limit number of
spikes then then maybe you just can't
store everything that you want to
store
um so all of these ideas essentially
point to some essentially biophysical
limit to why we have uh a working memory
capacity limit right so one challenge in
general is to answer why uh when we have
more neurons we cannot overcome this
limit uh for example the the human has
uh orders of several orders of magnitude
more neurons than monkey and mouse right
yet we have a working memory capacity
that is on the same order of magnitude
right it's in all case all these animals
have a capacity that is less 10 so how
come we have so many more neurons yet
comparable
capacity uh so there is one uh normative
idea out there which is working memory
is important for flexibility so this is
I want to acknowledge that this is uh
one idea that's really influential for
us um and and we kind of also started
wanting to test this idea so this is
idea that
sorry this is the idea that um for
working memory to be very very flexible
as we want them to be then you have to
pay a price and then you cannot storm
anything simultaneously because um so so
I won't go into the details but this is
kind of um our original hypothesis as
well so now um I'll tell you some more
detail about how this capacity limit is
uh tested in for example monkeys uh that
don't understand numbers right and you
can also use that for humans as well um
so here we focus on visual working
memory so this is where you show people
a sequence of pictures and they have to
kind of remember something about the
pictures uh in this particular Paradigm
uh which we'll call a change detection
task um you're first shown in the sample
period um like uh for example three
colored squares it can be uh it can be
less it can be more the number of color
squares is called the set size uh and
the arrow here is the time in the in the
task and so you're first shown these
three colored squares and then there's a
delay period when you don't see anything
it's just a gray uh gray screen and then
you see um another three squares that
appeared at the same location at the
original Three squares and mostly have
the same colors but with for example 50%
probability one of the colored Square
would change its color now the question
is uh to report whether or not there is
a change right here the chance level is
50% uh and then so if you ask people to
do it as you increase the set size right
which which is a number of colored
squares the percent correct really goes
down very rapidly so this is uh uh this
is the change detection task and then
there's a different Paradigm which is uh
you can call it a continuous report
task where you're again showed color
squares and then a delay but then
there's a q period when a single Q uh
stimulus is shown and you you need to
report the color uh of the square that
uh during the SE that was shown during
the seal period that's at the same
location as a q okay so so here uh
essentially you should report Orange
right because orange uh the orange
square is at the same location as a
black Square during the C period and you
need to report that on a color ring so
uh this task is is nice because we you
can assess the arrow of your report and
that arrow is a kind of a continuous
variable so there's a lot that you can
learn from that the distribution of that
Arrow uh and if you look at for example
how big that arrow is so this is a
standard deviation of your your report
uh and it grows very very rapidly with a
number of
items so now let's try to build neuron
networks that can do this um so I want
to say this is all the work done with uh
two talented students UDC and d u also
with help from Chris qua who's post do
in the lab um so first uh what we will
do is build uh a two System model that
involves a convolutional neuron Network
and a recurrent neuron Network so here
this convolutional neuron network is is
one of these models used uh to model the
visual systems and so people have shown
that um these models when train on large
uh
naturalistic uh visual data sets you can
obtain uh essentially neuron Network
models of the visual system as good as
it
gets and then we have uh these models
process the raw visual inputs right the
pixel inputs and then it will feed into
a recurrent neur Network which is then
asked to do the task so now in this
particular case uh we will train both
the convolutional neuron networks the
CNN and the recurrent neuron networks
the RNN on this single task uh we will
train the whole thing every connection
weight in these networks and what we see
here is that um in this so-called entent
train Network the performance is very
high right it doesn't depend on the set
size uh and so you you can do it
perfectly so it's it's nothing like the
humans and this is also true for the
continuous report task so it's way way
better than humus and now you might say
well this is not surprising right uh
it's 20203 we have Chad
GPT it's a big deal that neuron networks
are better than humans right um but
remember our original puzzle is exactly
why humans are so bad at this right we
want to understand why humans are bad at
this or when working memory looks like
an important function right and and
seeing that you can easily train uh some
neuron networks to beat
human kind of further emphasize this
puzzle uh but maybe uh but let let's
think about the hypothesis that others
have proposed right so one idea is that
uh we have limited number of spikes
right in the brain that's why that's why
uh we cannot remember this so well um so
so here we're using the so-called rate
neuron networks so we don't have spikes
but we can try to mimic the effect of
spikes by injecting noise into the
neural so this is just private noise
that try to corrupt the activity of the
neurons now uh we can also try to limit
the size of our Network try to make it
smaller and see if we can constrain the
capacity that way now it turns out if
you do that do either of these things it
doesn't work you can successfully bring
the overall performance down as expected
right if you inject lots of noises you
will essentially not be able to do any
task meaningfully right similarly if you
make your model very very small
it won't be able to do the task but the
way that it fails is interesting so here
again we're plotting the performance in
this change detection task as a function
of the set size and you can see that
when you make the model smaller or you
add noise the performance kind of
decrease in a uni uniform fashion unlike
the human where it's dependent on the
set size and we have some ideas why this
is happening but so this but when we
first saw this it was pretty interesting
right so so this suggests that uh at
least in our
networks um we cannot get humanlike
capacity limit by injecting noise um and
at least in these endtoend train
networks so what can we do now a very
natural thing to try is to uh instead of
train this convolutional neuron
Network um end to end to end right we
would take we would train it like the
way that Vision neuroscientists train
their networks uh meaning that we would
train the network on some uh
naturalistic visual data sets so what I
will show you is result where we train
the network uh on this pretty small data
set called Cipher 10 which is just a
classification data set um uh on some
natural images it's a small data set but
we have also tried that on larger data
set we have tried not just
classification task we have tried
self-supervised learning contrastive
training task uh and the results hold
but uh today I will only show you the
results on classifying on Cipher 10 okay
uh and VOA if you try these networks
then almost immediately you get a more
humanlike capacity limit right so I'm
under No Illusion that it's perfect
right it's but for us this is pretty
striking because we didn't do anything
right all we did is to train the
convolutional neuron networks on some
naturalistic task and we're also able to
match the
performance um almost
quantitatively in
the uh in the continuous report task so
I want to emphasize that this is not a
fit so we didn't try
to fit essentially fit the network to
these human behavior right all we did is
to train the convolutional network the
way that vision neuroscientists would
train them and then we're able to
capture this limit so these results
would suggest
that uh pre-training visual system is
actually sufficient to uh to obtain
humanik working memory limit and these
uh in these tasks so there's a caveat
but uh I'm happy to go into it in the
Q&A um but for the sake of time I'll
move on now and um I'll just also
briefly say that um besides these two
measures that I've shown you our models
can also match the data and many other
important measures that people have
looked at over the decade for example
when you have higher set size in the
continuous reports task you have wider
Arrow
distribution uh when the network or the
human is more confident your report tend
to be more accurate uh so your uh your
essentially
distribution uh of report is more
centered around the correct
option uh if you give
a q right not to be confused as a final
Q in the continuous report but but early
que that tells you where you're more
likely to be uh queued upon later then
you tend to be more accurate and our
Network can do that as well and then
finally uh you can vary the change uh uh
how big you change the color uh and
match what people have seen and animals
as well so we get all of these for free
right so none of we we didn't try to do
anything to match any
particular uh data set
here okay so this is uh this is a
flexible working memory part so just to
summarize uh here we're showing you just
by using a visual system uh that is
built in a way similar to how visual
neuroscientist would build them anyway
we're able to capture many many
phenomenas that people have observed in
working memory right which is suggesting
that working memory a thing that is
thought to be you know intuitively a
cognitive phenomena that if you have a
limit must be you know a cognitive
bottleneck we're able to see uh that we
can
actually explain it to some extent using
just a realistic uh visual
system okay so I hope this convinced you
that uh it's important to look at
multi-stem networks um but uh but
multi-stem networks are hard right and
I'll tell you why so first there are
many different ways to build your
sensory system right and there are many
different ways to build your cognitive
system but then you have more complexity
trying to put them
together and this this is just the
architecture but then when you throw
training in the mix as we have just seen
there are different ways that you can
train the network you can train the
network end to endend on some task or
you can pre-train some part of it on
some task and then train another part on
on another task right so there's a huge
variety of possibilities here right a
huge design space of these networks so
how do we navigate all this design space
right just to again talk about uh this
complexity for the RNN you can build
more biologically grounded continuous
time rnns or you can use more machine
learning type arens called lstms that
actually people don't really use in
machine learning anymore everyone
everyone use Transformers right right um
uh so so you can use these different
recurrent neuron networks and you can
also use different types of inputs to
your recurrent networks you can use very
simple stylized input like uh people
have done in the past or you can use
these convolutional networks as input
like I've shown you so so there's a lot
of complexity here so how do we navigate
that uh so one idea and it's not the
only idea but one
idea is to rely on quantitative scores
that can allow us to screen many many
models and lots of people have worked on
this right
for we feel pretty late to the game in
many ways but people have already used
this and the visual system extensively
been used to study the language
system um but here today we just want to
use it on the cognitive system and see
what we can find okay okay so I'll tell
you a bit more but this is work led by
post Chris qua with a really a brilliant
team of uh visiting students and interns
Nathan clu mofan Lee M POA and Katherine
Joe um so I've shown you this slide
earlier right where we have uh this is
essentially the classic Paradigm we have
a learning problem a neuron Network and
the learning Rule and we would get a
model and compare that to data right
simple as that now let's let's just uh
scale this up by looking at many many
data sets instead of one right what's
limiting us right let's look at a 100 um
but I'll only show you two today um so
then let's not just look at one type of
network and one type of learning rule
let's look at many types of networks
many types of learning rules Etc uh and
finally um once you have these many
networks and many data sets it helps to
have a way to
summarize uh the result that you get
from each Network and each data set
because you are going to have 10, or
more of these right so you cannot afford
to look at pictures like the night nice
pictures like I'm showing you on the
right but 10,000 times we cannot afford
that so let's let's summarize the model
data comparison into some quantitative
similarity score but in our case we'll
look at distance so the neural distance
essentially is lower if it's lower it
means uh the model is similar to the
experimental data okay um so for the
sake of time I'll actually skip this
slide um but I'm happy to come back to
it if people have questions but this is
just to say that that uh although we're
looking at quantitative scores it's also
important to to also do qualitative
analysis that people have developed many
many clever analysis that people have
developed um so that we can better
understand what it means when we have a
quantitative difference uh so I actually
explain it briefly so you can do some
qualitative analysis on some brain data
so here we have this data called cillo
2015 which is just monkey which is a
monkey uh reaching to different targets
and then recording from their uh motor
areas you can do see do some qualitative
analysis get some curves and then you
can do the same thing and I'll show you
results from two recurrent networks and
where you can see the network in the
middle is much more similar to the data
than the network on the right right so I
would call this a qualitative difference
that is revealed by this analysis
and when you do a
quantitative uh comparison you get you
can get this procus distance that Alex
Williams and colleagues have developed
recently and you and this distance range
from zero to one to half pi and zero
means it's the model and the data are
very close and you can see here that the
good Network the network that is close
to data has a distance of 0.6 and the
bad networks has a distance of 0 .8
right so here even a distance difference
in 0.2 can be
meaningful now we will look at this
procras distance on this particular data
set now uh on the y axis uh but what
should be our x-axis right so here I
will just briefly talk about different
ways that we can choose this x-axis and
how we can make many discoveries
depending on the x-axis and depending on
what we see for example we can plot on
the x-axis a training time when you
train a single neuron network uh and
naively uh you would imagine that as you
train the network uh it gets closer and
closer to the brain but it doesn't have
to be this way right it could be as you
train it it gets better and then as you
further train it it gets worse or it can
be at some point during the training
there's an Abrupt change that it gets
much closer to the
brain you can also plot on the xaxis the
task performance how well you do this
task after training and you can imagine
that the better you are at this task uh
the closer you are to the brain um so
here each dot would correspond to a
network a single Network and here we're
analyzing multiple
networks um but it Al you could also see
something like this where uh when you
get really really good at the task you
actually deviate from the brain right uh
and you can look at different types of
architectures and see that some of them
are really much closer to the brain than
others even when you control for the
task
performance and you can look at learning
rule variations right let's not just do
back prop
let's try some plasticity rules and you
can do this as well right so uh we have
done all of these um but I don't have
time to show you all of them uh and I
can but I can already tell you that
there are many interesting things that
we find and some are some are intuitive
and some are
counterintuitive but today I will show
you uh a different xaxis where we plot
the
distance when evaluate did on a
different data set so this is this mon
data set that I already explained in the
beginning it's a classical data set lots
of people have worked on it um but we
want to essentially look at how a single
network uh a uh how essentially a single
set of
hyperparameters perform in these two
data sets right so here essentially we
take one hyperparameter setting and we
would train two networks right with the
same hyperparameter setting each network
is trained on one of these task and
compare it to the corresponding data set
and then we can repeat that for
different hyper parameters right and by
that I mean different neuro
architectures different network size
different noise level Etc and there are
again many many things you could find
here right for example you could find
that there's a strong correlation across
data sets this would be nice because
this means that whatever you find in one
data set May translate to another data
set but this doesn't have have to happen
right it's possible that we find weak
correlation across data sets which would
raise a lot of questions about how much
you can translate your your findings
from one data set to another right uh
you could see very little variations
across
hyperparameters right in this case it
suggests that the Performing the task
would give you very strong constraint on
this solution uh that there would be
very little variations across them as
long as they can do the task but uh you
can also even in this case uh it depends
you can have consistently bad models or
you can have consistently good models
right again when the distance are
smaller the network is closer to the
brain then finally you can add you can
also color the dots uh differently right
according to let's say the neural
architecture or something else and you
could see that some architectures
consistently outperform other
architecture or some architectures or
the architectures are similar or one
architecture is better than the other
architecture but only for one data set
but not for the
other so I went through all these
possibilities to show you that there are
really many things that we can learn in
these plots and it's really unclear what
we will learn because people haven't
really done these plots a lot for
cognitive
Neuroscience uh so next I will show you
exactly uh what we found when we did
this
analysis uh and here's so so before we
go into the details so here's what we
did for each task we trained a San 620
networks that are the full combination
of three neuro architectures three
activation functions three Network sizes
four types of regular
regularizations three noise levels and
five random seats so there's a lot you
can analyze here but we will only color
them by architectures now and you can
but you can focus on different AES if
you want um and there are many things
there are four things that we found in
this pilot analysis and all the networks
I'm showing you also have task
performance above a threshold so they
all perform the task similarly well uh
what we find is that one these
continuous time Arns these are networks
that are more biologically grounded are
actually uh uh better than the machine
learning was um although they're not
like just you know uh they're not like
uh better in the sense that the worst uh
continuous Time network is better than
the best lsdm right so here we see
there's a lot of overlap but the best
continuous time networks tend to be
better than
lstms uh we also see that there's
substantial variability across
hyperparameters so this is confirming
something that many people have observed
uh in practice but I don't think people
have reported that widely uh yet at
scale that when you train networks there
is actually a great amount of
variability um in terms of brain
similarity uh in these specific two data
sets we see a correlation um but I can
already tell you that when we look at
more data sets we don't always see a
correlation so it's interesting to study
why sometimes we see correlation and
sometimes we don't and finally we see
that uh here we have this dash line and
I don't have time to explain that but
this is essentially a strong Baseline
and we see that when we train the
network uh we can beat the Baseline
quite often but sometimes it's actually
worse than the Baseline which suggests
that uh training Network alone really
doesn't guarantee you to have um and
these cognitive test to have neuron
networks that are similar to the brain
right which raise caution to analyzing
these
networks uh before we kind essentially
figured out a consistent way to build
good
networks so with that I'll end uh by
just saying that today I've shown you
just a little piece of uh everything
we're trying to do essentially focusing
on some hypothesis driven qualitative
analysis for working memory and some
hrut quantitative analysis for recurrent
networks but there's a lot more to do
and
um uh and of course uh nothing would be
possible without people uh in the lab
who actually did the work in particular
UD and danu leted the working memory
part and Chris qua leted the second part
on recurrent Networks and also special
thanks for Manuel Milano who I wrote the
opinion piece with and of course uh our
funding sources and uh all our
collaborators over the years uh thank
you well thank you Dr young for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen so let's get
started it looks like we have a couple
of questions uh let's see we've got one
question coming in now Dr Young our
audience member says about the working
memory part what happens if you show
that stimuli sequentially instead of
simultaneously okay thank you uh thank
you for this question I mean I asked it
myself so to give people time uh to to
type up their own questions now I know
there are many many things uh here that
uh that I went through quickly so you
know feel free to ask uh whatever you
want um happy to go into details any of
this but uh first I'll just answer this
question I asked myself uh okay so in
this working memory part right uh let me
let me show you this um so I've shown
you that
if we
um if we pre-train the convolutional
network then we can obtain a human like
capacity limage right so the implication
here is that okay we can we simply
cannot remember all these things maybe
because we cannot even see them
simultaneously right but then of course
the psychologists and cognitive
scientists have thought about this
possibility a long time ago and they
have tested Ed it in humans by instead
of showing uh the stimuli
simultaneously you can show them
sequentially right you can show them one
at a time or you can show them
simultaneously but allow humans to look
at them as long as as long as they want
so they can potenti they can look at
them essentially
sequentially themselves and people have
shown that even in this case uh you
would have a working memory capacity
limit so now can our result explain that
can our Network explain
it um so so this is one of the biggest
this is probably the biggest uh catch of
the results I'm showing you now U which
is um if we do this sequentially and
then then you can uh with this network I
showed you it actually still sees a
capacity limit but then you can increase
your recurrent Network size you can make
it larger and then you would no longer
see a capacity limit u in the sense that
you can get your capacity to be as high
as you want as long as you have a large
recurrent Network which is uh intuitive
right because uh if you show things
sequentially then your visual system is
no longer constraining constraining you
it's no longer limiting you and if you
have a very large cognitive system here
the recurrent Network then you should be
able to just do uh as well as you want
so this uh so we do know that if we keep
the recurrent Network size small uh
enough then we can limit the capacity
limit I want to say that alone is
non-trivial because um before I've shown
you in this end case that keeping the
network size small doesn't necessarily
lead to humanik capacity limit it will
give you some limit all right but not
necessarily humanlike so the fact that
we can limit the recurrent Network size
and see humanlike limit is already
encouraging but of course in the brain
that shouldn't be the right constraint
because in the brain we know that we
have many many neurons in our parietal
cortex and our prefrontal cortex so I
think there's a lot to be done here to
understand the kind of realistic
constraint that is posed to our
recurrent networks uh to for us to have
capacity limit in the sequential
presentation
case well thank you so so much Dr Young
and our next question coming in our
audience member says I want I'm was
wondering if you could comment on the
nature of explainability of this broader
class of models yeah great question and
and thank you because this is a this is
a session on explainable AI right and I
kind of
I kind of didn't explicitly talk about
that and thank you for giving me this
opportunity to comment on that um so I
want to say uh explainability is a of
course a general problem for AI but um
they show up in different ways uh if
you're building self-driving car right
and your car makes a makes a
mistake uh or or make some decision just
for accountability you would like to be
able to understand why it makes it
decision right so that's that's
explainability for the AI part now for
the
brain um I think for at least for me the
ultimate goal is to build neuron
networks that are like the brain um and
and I don't think the brain is
necessarily explainable in the sense
that it's it's not necessarily
explainable in the way that we want it
to be explainable right
uh in some way there is no evolutionary
pressure for the brain to be explainable
to neuroscientist uh we can try to
explain it but uh but uh we may have our
we may hit our limit um so personally I
don't think it's a huge problem that the
brain uh is fundamentally difficult to
explain in our neuron Network models of
them are fundamentally difficult to
explain now with that said it doesn't
mean we should not try right so uh so I
think uh neuroscientists our job is to
try to explain the brain despite the
challenge and people that's why people
have um designed all these clever
behavioral tasks behavioral analysis
qualitative neural analysis right uh and
I've shown you some today right where uh
we can for example do this fancy
dimensionality reduction um the
neuroactivity we can do very targeted
analysis on the on the behavior and
these will help us understand the brain
and mind and this will you can apply the
same analysis and this will help us
understand neuron networks so this is a
long-winded answer but just to
summarize uh I think
explainability in a neur network models
for the brain is different from
explainability and AI in
general uh and it's okay that our neuron
networks are not necessarily that
explainable um U but we should still try
to explain it this same same way or in
better ways that we try to explain the
brain uh I hope I hope that uh I can't
can't see I can't see people's facial
expression so hope that makes sense to
people absolutely thank you so much Dr
Young And I want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we
go yeah
um so uh so I want to say uh we're doing
so today this is kind of of a high level
view right with some opinion pieces uh
if you if you want to hear more about it
uh uh please please feel free to reach
out in particular um people in the lab
will be very happy to give uh in detail
uh explanation of their work and if
you're going to cosign we're presenting
some of these uh the cosign conference
starting tomorrow uh oh sorry that
someone said lost connection frequently
I mean I'm I'm sorry about that there's
little I can do about that uh it is it
Me Maybe the MIT Wi-Fi is bad uh you're
you're
fine
okay well well we do want to thank you
again for your time and for your
important research and before we go I
also want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information information you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until March 8th
20125 labach will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone and bye bye
bye
I